[MUSIC]
I want to spend the first 20 minutes
talking sort of, I guess about the pen
world tables and related data sets and
the facts of economic growth.
So kind of a big picture overview of
some of the important facts of growth.
And then for the second 20 minutes
Look at the US census data and
American Community Survey and
some work that I've done with Pete and
Chang Shay and Eric Kirsten and john Felix
ray is a graduate student at Stanford.
On in some sense the mis
allocation of talent.
So Pete talked about mis allocation of
a lot of firms than this will focus on mis
allocation at the individual person level.
Okay, but for the first part, we talked
about the effects of economic growth here.
>> Yeah, so facts and then I use MATLAB
and so I made up The MATLAB code
available for reading the pin world
tables or for reading the census data.
And I'll spend a minute or
2 at the end of each of these
halves talking about that code.
>> Okay, so the first part of
this comes from this handbook for
economic growth chapter that
I wrote several years ago.
Here's just sort of
one way of looking at
many countries or
regions in the world.
Where from 1980 to 1985.
Maybe they fell slightly further behind
maybe that was due to rapid growth in
the United States, right.
But then the numbers
are something like 65 or
75% I've presented the US and
then Japan obviously was growing really
rapidly but before this period and
then that continued into basically 1990.
So you can see Japan moving
up to actually 85% of the US.
We know well France and
the UK don't seem to be 75% of the US.
Is that really right?
And how do we think about that?
But you know, sort of 75 percents,
the number that comes out of the pin
world tables when you look at GDP.
You could see Brazil there Russia there,
China, obviously, China and India,
two countries that are very interesting
from a growth standpoint just because
they've exhibited such rapid
growth recently, right?
So you can see
China's starts in
1988 about
7% of the US
that's what,
you know 7% growth
per year does for
you, right?
So that's what 7% growth
per year looks like there.
India starts out further
behind it some number like 3.
And from, you know,
some pizza chains work for example,
you remember that there were big reforms
in the early 1990s and continuing.
So you can see India, kind of lagging
China a little bit, maybe by, you know,
10 or 15 years, but you know now, in 2017,
we're reaching about 11 or 12% of us.
And then finally Sub Saharan Africa.
You see kind of a different pattern here,
which is in 1980.
SubSaharan Africa as
a region had about 10% or
11% of the GDP per person,
the United States.
That they fell further and further behind.
So in 2000, this number is more like 4%.
So this is another way of saying
the United States grew faster and
GDP per person.
Then SubSaharan Africa as an entity,
but that switched after 2000.
You can see they went back up to seven or
8%.
So this is sort of is one way
of seeing the broad growth
patterns across a range of countries.
Here's another graph that I'm showing
you that shows similar data just just
differently.
On the horizontal axis is GDP per person.
On the vertical in 1960.
On the vertical axis is
GDP per person in 2017.
And so you can see a bunch of
interesting things in this graph,
maybe one big picture point,
let me make now because I'll come back
to this a little bit later as well.
Imagine I hadn't labeled the country so
you just saw the blue circles.
With overlapping labels, it's not good so
when we're publishing
a paper I'll go in and
clean out, cut out some of
the labels that are overlapping.
So it's got a routine
that does a little bit
of selecting where to put the label,
but it's not great.
So label your data.
I care a lot about
the quality of the figures.
You want to communicate
as clearly as possible.
And that'll hopefully come
through in my presentation.
So what else can you see here?
So everything's relative to
the United States being
one if you look at the,
the poorest countries
of the world in 1960,
versus today, interestingly,
look at the scale of the axis.
It cuts off at 1/64 of the US in 1960.
And it cuts off at 1/128
of the US in 2017.
And that's sort of another way
of saying an interesting point,
which is The gaps between the richest and
poorest countries have gotten bigger
over time not smaller, but that counts by
country instead of by person and it turns
out those those if you different views
of the way world inequalities change.
So I'll come back to
that point in a second.
Obviously countries that
are high above the line here,
this is a 45 degree line
that I've got in blue.
If you're high above the line,
you've increased you've grown faster
the United States, you've increased
in this graph and the position.
And if you're below the 45 degree
line you've grown more slowly than
the United States.
So you've fallen behind the United States.
And you can see there are a bunch of
countries in both of those groups.
So 2% growth of GDP per person,
the United States, which you might think
of is something, what should be possible
to everyone, even at the frontier.
Yeah, a bunch of countries
fall short of that,
a bunch of countries that
have done better than that.
Okay hold on one second,
I'm going to change what I wanted to here.
I'm not sure I could totally see if you
raise your hand so if you have a question.
Raise your hand I think I've noticed the I
think I just moved something around so
I can see.
Here's another really cool fact
that Alex picked David coasts and
Nicole cube shindell have an Tomoko
part and pepper salad and
have all made a big deal out of in
some recent papers and that is.
As countries get rich, eventually their
average hours work starts to decline.
Okay, and so you could just see this in
many, many countries and they have data.
They Big like ACO strictiond on paper
emphasizes micro data property for
sale use more sort of existing
summary data across countries but
going back really far in time.
This is a very robust fact.
You can see it's not always an area
issue so South Korea and when it first
started growing rapidly workers in
South Korea started working harder.
But even in South Korea where they were
working more than 2,800 hours per worker,
by the end of the 1980s, plummeted a lot.
So down to, 2200 or even less.
But you see the same pattern in Japan and
France and UK and even in the US.
The US is one of the smallest
declines I would say, an hour's work.
But the 2000 hours per worker
in 1950 now looks more like
1800 hours per worker today
in the United States.
So, thinking about what,
what's behind these broad patterns
I would say, and this is a hit.
You can see in a lot of my papers,
probably half my research papers,
have the following character.
Identify a key fact in the data that no
one's going to argue with like this fact
no one's going to argue with it.
It is true, it is robust.
And then ask well can you write
down a model where that happens?
And does that model have extra
implications that might be interesting.
I mean, can you can make it happen not
just qualitatively but quantitatively.
What explains why people in South Korea
work so much harder than people In Japan.
What explains the upward trend and then
the downward trend DCL looking at trends
and try to explain them, half my papers
are kind of that character I think.
So that's a way I like to do research
some infatuated with graphs like this.
Okay, I mentioned before that,
when you look at the country level,
it looks like the rich countries are even
richer I than the poor countries.
The gaps have kind of widened so global
inequalities increase if you look at
the country level but it certainly not
not true at the individual level and
that's really important.
This graph, I would say, you know,
because growth economists don't typically
look at the individual level, we don't
emphasize it as much as we should.
But it's probably,
the first graph you should show in any
class on economic growth at some sense.
So what does this graph so
the horizontal axis is GDP per person.
Relative to the US being one in 2017.
So, I'm going to show you data for
1960 and 2017, but
the US is equal to one only in 2017.
Okay, so the US would be I don't know,
a factor of three poor US would be 0.33.
>> Sorry.
>> Yeah,
I got it right used to be 0.33 in 1960, so
that's where the US is right up here.
Good.
Okay, so what do you see what I've done
here is I've assigned each person in every
country, their own GDP per person.
So you can see China and India are these
big jumps and the vertical axis sorry,
I slipped.
Sure this is right.
This is what fraction of the world's
population lives in countries with GDP
per person less than whatever the number
is on the horizontal axis okay.
And so I've written the summary
here to help remind me what to say.
In 1960, two out of three
people in the world lived in
countries with GDP per person,
less than 5% of today's us.
So less than about $7 per day.
So if we go to where the two thirds
point is, it right in here, right?
You'll see, that's at about
1/12 of the US, income I think.
So 5% it would be 120.
Right?
So, the data here probably and
I couldn't draw my lines across.
All right, so two out of three people in
the world in 1960 were very, very poor.
What fraction of the world's
population today lives at that
same level $7 per day are less
than 5% of today's 2017 level.
The answer is only one added 12 right so
what was the point that was
here is now way down here.
And you can see,
a big part of that is China and
India with, kind of, two and a half,
three billion people in the world.
As China and India grow rapidly
that's lifted two and a half or
three billion people out
of this extreme poverty.
And that's an incredibly
impressive achievement, right?
So at the individual level, there's
been a decline in global inequality,
even if at the country level there hasn't,
there's been an increase.
I think the individual level is kind of
in for this question what we care about.
So as I mentioned this treats each person
within a country as having the same
income which is obviously not true.
You could do better and
various people have tried to bring this to
the data as well using some of the world
wealth and inequality database.
Chevy Sally Martini revenue
various other people
added within country and
equality in this graph.
And it just reinforces
the point basically.
So, the changes within country and
equality are small.
Relative to these big gains
in income per person that
we see in places like China and India.
Okay, now I want to shift
gears to a paper with Pete.
I think this these first two hours
are all about Pete's papers.
I think is one way to look at it.
This paper where we did the following
go back to that France example Where I
said France turns out to have
about 70% of the GDP per person.
The United States and
if you look at consumption per
person it would be about 65%.
People in France are surprisingly poor
when you just look at consumption.
And, when I go to France, France seems
like it's a pretty successful country and
has some some things to like about it.
So, is there something
wrong with the GDP numbers?
It's kind of partly the motivation for
this.
And when you look at the data,
one thing you appreciate is that
sure France has low consumption.
But France has high life expectancy.
People in France live about two years
longer than people in the United States.
They don't work that hard, but
that means they have a lot of leisure.
All right, so people in France have
more leisure than the United States, and
inequality is lower.
So behind the veil of ignorance,
you're going to be born as a random
person in the United States or France.
Where would you rather be
born as a random person?
Well, the inequality piece of it if I
say you're going to be a poor person,
you'd rather be a poor person in France.
I think so that the inequality is going
to be bigger in the United States and
behind the veil of ignorance we'd
like some insurance against that.
So that's going to that's in some
sense a reduction for the US as well.
So what we do in this paper is we write
down a standard utility function or
the kind that economists use to study,
asset pricing or exchange rates.
Or international trade or business
cycles or everything else labor supply,
write down a standard utility function
that also includes years of life.
So you add up over your years of life,
your u of C comma L and
your consumption is uncertain your
leisure might be uncertain as well.
And so we take that inequality
into account we ask,
what's the consumption equivalent welfare?
Put everything on consumption units.
How much would you have to give up take
take take away from a French person
to have them suffer the low life
expectancy in the United States and
be indifferent there.
So that's the kind of
question we're asking.
And what you can see in this chart on
the horizontal axis is GDP per person.
US equal one, on the vertical
axis is the welfare number and
I realized I'm going too slowly
right I need to speed up.
And they're highly correlated so
the correlation is .95.
So the first thing is,
sure all these other things matter but
GDP per person is a good summary
statistic, there's a reason why we use it.
But that's not the entirety
of the story and
if you look closely you can see a bunch
of rich countries are above the line and
the poor countries are disproportionate
below the line and so
the gaps are large, so on vertical axis
now the horizontal axis is the same.
On the vertical axis I have
the ratio of welfare to income,
so how much higher is consumptional
equivalent to welfare than the income
comparison would suggest would suggest and
look at France for example,
France is about 30% richer than
their income would suggest.
And so instead of being 65% or
70% of the US,
France is going to look like 90 or
95% of the US in these calculations and
you can see the UK,
Sweden are going to be like it.
There are other countries, poor countries
in the world, most of the countries
are below the one and so they're many
countries to get deductions, okay?
So let me show you some of these picking
out some of the countries to show you
what's going on.
So life expectancy that the actual
numbers for the variable,
life expectancy in the US is about 78
years, our consumption to GDP ratio
is about 85%, hours worked in the US
not per worker but per person is 836 so
this is the opposite of leisure in
blue but it's the leisure adjustment.
And then consumption inequality the
standard deviation of log consumption in
the US is something like 65 to 66%, okay.
So now France GDP per person for
2007 here was 70% of the US,
but as I said people
in France live longer,
I guess it's three years
instead of two years.
They have high lower consumption
I already said that,
they work less 600 hours rather than 800
hours, so that's a lot less work and
a lot lower inequality standard
deviation of log consumption,
47% instead of 66%,
how much is each of those worth?
Well interestingly the inequality
adds 10%, lower inequality as 10%,
higher leisure only had 6% you might
think maybe it should add even more,
we were being conservative here, right?
600 hours versus 836 hours but
it only adds 6 or
7% with our standard preferences.
Longer life expectancy, each year of life
is worth about 5% of consumption, right?
So three years gives you about 16%,
when you add all those things up,
France looks like 90% of the US
rather than 70% of the US.
Let me go down again in the interest
of time we pick a very poor country
like Botswana, which doesn't look
poor when you look at their GDP.
25% of the US one of the richest
countries in Sub Saharan Africa,
but when you look,
they have lower life expectancy much lower
because of AIDS in this period,
52 years versus 77 years.
Remember each year of life is
worth about 5% of consumption, so
this knocks off 77 log points, right?
They work slightly harder and there's
even more inequality in Botswana and
the inequality reduces consumption
equivalent welfare by 33%.
So instead of looking like 25% of the US,
instead of being pretty impressive on
a consumption equivalent welfare basis
Botswana looks even poor, like 5% of
the US and we find this in general.
So Western Europe, looks closer to the US
because you add in there longer lives and
there higher leisure,
the poorest countries the world look
even poor when you do things this way.
Okay, let's see what I want to do,
I'm going to, I love these facts,
these are my new papers, so
these are graphs and charts.
>> [CROSSTALK] Chad just so
you keep going take a few extra minutes
because we do have some margins.
>> Okay I'll yeah, as Pete said I think I
get too excited and quit too many things.
Okay all right, so another cool
fact about the world which you
might not appreciate it,
ask yourself what happens to
global population 100 years from now,
does it level off?
Does it keep growing?
If you'd asked me a year and a half ago
I'd have said, my guess is going to level
off like I don't know, eight or
9 billion people, something like that.
It turns out all of the rich countries in
the world have fertility rates
below replacement, okay?
What do I mean here?
How many kids does each
woman have on average?
And two kids per woman on
average would be replacement,
that would be maintaining
a constant population.
If you look at high income
countries as a whole,
they have 1.7 kids per woman,
the U S is 1.8,
China 1.7 Germany 1.6, Japan,
Italy, Spain even less.
And as as countries get richer,
the fertility rates decline, that's a fact
that you probably knew, what I hadn't
quite appreciated, you might have thought,
well they level off at two somehow but
as soon as you see that he runs well,
there's nothing special from an individual
family standpoint about two kids.
And in fact when we look at India,
they used to have six kids per woman,
then five, then four, then three and
now 2.5, you can see they're headed for
this two and
you're not going to stop necessarily.
And if we look at all the other countries
in the world that have gotten rich,
they haven't stopped,
they've gotten right below two.
So I have a paper that I
won't talk anymore about but
it's called the end of economic growth.
So the growth models I like population
plays a very important role because people
produce ideas.
So if actually the future of global
population is declining because we're
having fewer than two kids for
one, that might actually lead to
well it's the Empty Planet,
the book that I took these facts from.
There's a book the title Empty Planet, but
it actually leads to the end of economic
growth as well and so you'd have this
stagnation of living standards on a planet
that gradually empties of people.
And this is a very different view of
growth from our standard view where we
say, exponential growth and
living standards for
a population that grows exponentially,
right?
That's the view I had of growth
before I worked on this paper and
now I realize well it's not quite so
clear.
Finally there's some growth accounting.
This is a another new thing that I've
done that kind of lays out where
does growth come from,
in this one I think I will skip because
I'm taking time from my next session.
So I mentioned these
programs are available,
there's a collection of subroutines that
I've written called in ChadMatlab.zip.
And here are the key programs that you
need to read the pin world tables and
to make the graphs that I've made and it
shows you how to label the countries, and
here's some some code to
help your graphs look nice.
[MUSIC]